you
my name is celery and I myself engineer
at dinner breaks firmly working on the
open source project called ml Lib the
one I'm going to talk about it today
and but it was a kind of like a one over
talk but I need to ask a few questions
to decide which part I just escaped its
hominis back users and how many of you
have used a mehleb okay so how many
people went to yesterday's meetup is
another spark meetup is talking about
pipelines it's a I think yesterday down
upstairs and how many of you know
alternatingly says cars okay let's start
with a mallet Emily it's a component of
spark but we should say a little bit a
few sentences about spark spark is a a
fast and general engine for big data
processing is think about MapReduce but
faster and it's kind of like a most
active open source project in the big
data world we have more than 500
contributors contributing to the project
and now we have more than 10,000
Camille's committed we have just have a
1.3 released last week so definitely
ages that go to a SPARC website download
it and try it out and SPARC is the most
interesting feature for SPARC is it's
actually very simple to use and is go up
to terabytes of data and you can choose
your own language
we provide Python Java Scala and sequoia
interface also there is a plant we
include a spark our that provided our
interface to spark you can just write
word count maybe just in less than 100
word and gaba is go up to terabytes of
data we just want the salt benchmark
last year and too short 100 terabytes in
I think it's in 20 minutes
and for spark if you're not that
familiar with sparked our two most
important concepts of spark the first
one is called our DD resilient
distributed data set it's a how you
distributed data to a caster and how you
described the mappings between those
data sets it doesn't do the computation
where you define a data set and then as
the only compute the those data sets in
pipelines we when you ask for some
results and sparkle show support caching
and you can cache your data in memory or
on disk to enhance data locality so it's
very useful for machine learning
applications because most of the machine
learning problems you need to you need
some iterative algorithm to solve it and
with traditional MapReduce and for each
iteration you have to relate load the
data from HDFS that's extremely slow and
spark a spark is very easy to get 100x
speed up compared to MapReduce a spark
is also a unified framework and provided
couple standard components like spark
Seco streaming and of course is sequoias
for structured queries and streaming is
for streaming data processing and today
I'm going to talk about a model for
machine learning and we also have a
component called graphics for graph
processing and it works really friendly
with the hot dog world so for example
spark doesn't have a storage layer we
can talk to you directly talk to HDFS
and through Hadoop improved formats and
we can talk to Amazon s3 as a storage
layer and we integrate Y always for
example Cassandra I chose HBase so it's
it's a good player in the Hadoop
ecosystem and so I'm from dinner breaks
the network's is a small company funded
by the creators of spark so we are the
main German falls behind spark and we're
building our product on top of open
source park the product is called the
public's cloud
we provide hosted solutions for
a managing spark clusters and also on
top of it will provide interactive
workspace and you can also just schedule
production jobs and we also have
partners who build third-party
applications on top of it we will have a
small demo today so thought of course
for machine learning and we're also
hiring so if you want to move to San
Francisco and just let us know so then
let's talk about Emma Lib so Emma lip is
initially from Berkeley and lab the same
place SPARC was born so if she plays
Park as a standard component it's in 0.8
and now we at 1.3 it's about one year
and a half old
so it's a very young project but it's
very active
we have contributions from modern
factory organizations and we have more
than 100 contributors so for each talk I
gave I just have a script to count the
number of contributors this I know is
increasing really fast and we have a
good coverage of algorithms
classification regression
clustering recommendation surely well
kind of like a table content you see
when you open machine learning textbook
we also have some infrastructure or
utilities for machine learning jobs like
how to do this feature transformation
feature extraction statistics some
linear algebra and also some data mining
tools and I want to give a brief history
just tell a little bit about history of
an OLAP initially instead 0.8 a yeren
half ago and just similar to every
machine learning library we start with
some algorithms and initially we have
linear linear algorithms and k-means and
alternating leases course I was supposed
Scala and visible Java and for the
optimization part we implement gradient
descent and then after three months we
have a three month development cycle for
SPARC and in 0.9 we are the native beers
for the API is special at a Python API
so there are a lot of Python users
definitely much more than Scala users
and so we also support Python for in
AMOLED then another three months in 1.0
and we just try to boost the the
performance by just a support in sparse
data we can explore exploit sparsity and
for both storage and computation but
rather the limited memory idea BFGS and
for algorithms we added decision tree
PCA and SVD so at this time we have seen
started seeing users start using it in
their production jobs and because this
is an open source project it's hard to
know who is using it who download it so
we have a good community and people will
ask questions on the user mailing list
and just by morning him that list I kind
of have a feel about how many users are
using it show them in 1.1 we added some
statistics to box and non-negative
matrix factorization some streaming
linear regression integration with
integrated with spark streaming and work
of act as a feature extractor and on the
optimization set we introduced some
three reduce and torrent broadcast to
just in church to boost the performance
to I think it's a about 5x but there are
more users there were more users using
an olive at that time but you see here
and there is a gap between the algorithm
part and the application part so we
didn't just think a lot about the API
side so whether is you whether is this
easy for users to just build
applications based on all the algorithms
we provide and that's a question that's
actually the first part of my talk today
and then in 1.2 we introduced this
pipeline API and I just tried to fill in
this gap and now users can easily build
machine learning pipelines using this
pipeline API for awkward suicide where I
added random forest gradient booster
trees those tree
and samples and also streaming k-means
now with 1.3 released last week and we
added a lot of algorithms and Lda for
topic modeling Matti Gnomeo logistic
regression constant mixture model and
also some isotonic regression for scale
calibration and FP grows for the many
frequent itemsets and also power
iteration clustering is as special
casting algorithm and besides those
algorithms we also launched a website
called spark packages so basically there
are for many users they have very
expensive need for their machine
learning applications we cannot just
include everything into an ellipse
because it just it becomes really hard
to maintain so we have to say for some
algorithms maybe it's good for the
developers to maintain outside spark and
then we launched this third-party
package index and for users they can to
find developers and for developers to
get feedback from users and in this
release we have the pipeline API in
Python also we have the model positions
for some models optimization part we
just really rewrote the errors algorithm
so you can scale up to billions of
readings that's the second part of my
talk today and we talked about the
history show and hoping with I not live
for about one year so this is my
understanding of with the goal of an
OLAP we try to make practical machine
learning easier and scalable so it
should be easier to build real world
machine learning applications and you
should be able to scale up to real world
data set it's a large-scale data service
with a couple terabytes so but that's
the testicle here this definitely is not
a collection of algorithms we learned
kind of lessons from the hood the hood
has been there for a couple years and
it's try to do a collection of
algorithms but they become how to use
and how to maintain and
the deprecated money algorithm because
just because about Noah little a few
people use it and a few people very few
people knows how to how this algorithm
works we try to include them those well
studied algorithms definitely now some
algorithms published this year and
because we don't even know that if user
asked questions we don't know how to
support it and the question is how we
can just just go back to the one point
one place so we have a list of
algorithms and we special users using it
further to develop their applications
and how we can just help users to
develop their own machine learning
applications let's first talk about the
requirements and starting from an
example machine learning workflow so for
example this is a tax classification
problem you start with some labeled
documents and you have the label and you
have the text for it and then you do
some feature transformation first you
organize the text and then you do a
hashing TF is a term frequencies you get
feature vectors then you can use
logistic regression to train a
classification model and after that you
can do some evaluation and see you is
your model working well and this is a
very simple workflow but I would say
it's really hard to do this in practice
and think about what you may ask well I
see for each part actually it's not that
hard for each component I can think
about maybe four or five libraries to do
it a feature extraction I can use a know
TK and I can use them or LP Jews and for
logistic regression I can use lip linear
I can use Weka I can use R and for
evaluation definitely there are many
other libraries I can use but the
problem is you need to connect them
together into a pipeline and think about
if I use all TK for
tokenizer and for hashing TF then I use
linear to solve logistic regression I
need to learn how to use each of them
and how to connect them for Libya nari
has a very specific format I need to
translate the output from an article
into linear to to do that another
problem is you also need to reapply the
entire pipeline we will make predictions
and that's the deep well it's very
similar to the training data but without
labels but sometimes you need to update
your code a lot just to do this
prediction that's that's the best thing
here and what makes this even complex
more complex is Virginie to tune
parameters for each of those components
you have couple parameters per tune for
example hashing TF you need to know well
what's the future dimension for the
output terms term vectors and for regret
regression logistic regression you need
to config regulations have
regularization constant number of
iterations freedom may fund maybe three
or four parameters hyper parameters but
you put them together and that's the
product of those and you the parameter
space grows exponentially and now you
want to find the best model and this is
kind of hard and purely think about if
you use one library for tokenization and
another library for logistic regression
then while you are running on top of
that you want to tune parameters this is
hard also another part of the problem is
data import so now we have a label
document if this is a modulating task as
school you get the training data
directly which contains labels and
features but in practice you need to
prepare this training data set for
example if this is a spam detection
problem and user may just mark some
document as spam and if user click that
mark this as one span
you get an event event record just going
through ETL maybe to some HDFS location
and inside this you want you let's
imagine that it may have this document
ID user ID and the click time and those
are the event logs and now you want to
do some content based analysis and to
identify span articles but you need to
find the content of this article and
this may live on inside a database right
so it may be a maybe an icicle database
or some HBase and now you need to just a
fetch data from two different sources
and join them together and to get your
training data set and this is not that
easy and if you are dealing with but
multiple they are data sources and let's
see in one point one what we have in an
OLAP the first part I just mentioned
data import and export we want to load
the data in and you want to save your
data out we support the best VN from
that it's a tax based format you have
label and then you have index and value
pairs and visual power save as the best
VM load Ledesma and file and we have our
own format will put indices together and
put values together and you can use
label points to load those label points
and you can also use Java serialization
Python pickling to serialize in human
and readable data so but the problem is
with support those very specific
specific format and what if I want to
have some additional field to save
together with or load together with the
training data for example I want to have
IDs I in the prediction I definitely I
don't see all just that zero or call a
single column with zero or once I want
to see the prediction along with the
document IDs and fuckton this is Lepus v
vm format is just for supervisor
learning it contains the label but why
I'm doing is I'm a super
while earning so do i but I have to keep
this label field it's definitely not
very flexible and Russia wants you say
we can load from different data sources
and when I shall save to different data
sources for example save directly to a
database and used by your online server
to just display to do the prediction and
this is one requirement the second
requirement is missing we were missing
high level api's and at that time it's
really hard to define workflow so we
need to just write your own code like I
mentioned to just a chain those
components even we provide all these
those components but it's hard to
connect them and we don't have a
built-in support for hyper parameter
tuning this is really essential for
practical machine learning pipelines no
one can guess was the best set of
parameters so you need a machine to just
decide for you and the last part is so
you early in Big Data is a really long
pipeline and if you make any error
mistake at some stage all the earth all
of the rest well very likely become
garbage and you we need to choose to for
use easily inspect every every step and
we want to check the output but this is
not that easy because for example for
model training we we really care about
the features we don't we don't we don't
want to see the extra metadata so it's
expensive if want to carry them over but
in prediction and we want to validate I
want to check the result I want to see
well this is the ID and this is the
prediction and this is the original tax
put them together does it make sense
right so we want to provide tools for
this model inspection and our solution
is this amount of haplin's API it's just
a try to make pipeline creation and
pipeline tuning easier for users and
it's built on top of the data frames API
and we release data frame in
1.3 and basically it's a how many users
have used our data frames or pandas Oh a
lot good so basically this is the same
set of API we inspired by pandas and but
works for big data sets and is backed by
the spark cycle engine which can do this
exact execution plan up and for you so
basically we feel how some aggregate or
filter it doesn't give you that data set
it just gives you the description of the
data data set and when you try to use it
and you try to do this all the
optimizations for you try to reduce the
sample size and try to reduce the number
of stages and it support basic C code
types like double extreme and he also
support dense vector and sparse vectors
just through the user different hubs
from machine learning we really won't
need sparse vectors because if we use
feature transformation it's very easy to
get a vector of size million 1 million
but a lot of them are zeros and well we
can use spark circles external data
sources to support multiple data sources
like HDFS as three hive or any while
database that support a DB Co JDBC and
it's very easy to load the data in from
multiple data sources and join them
together to prepare your training data
set so we don't have enough time to just
introduce the new frames API so to check
our website the spark website also there
are a couple videos online - about
thinner frames API basically the first
part is the RDP API if we want to
compute the average of address for each
department and the second is the data
frame API but if you have already
familiar with our or pandas but this is
the same for you and then after we have
the abstraction
for machine learning data sets and now
we want to define pipeline components
this is inspired by the Sakhalin project
is the popular machine learning of
library in Python and we define the
following abstractions for pipelines and
the first one is transformer a
transformer is easy and it just
transformed one oh sorry
it stretched from one didn't have frame
into another data frame and then the
concept is asked you made her the
estimator is giving you the training
data set you give me a model that's an
estimator the model itself is a is a
transformer and it can just transform a
data frame to another data frame with
predictions and then the pipeline is is
a list of Transformers and iced tea
meters and we will fit a pipeline the
pipeline itself is an estimator so when
you fit a pipeline you just go through
every stage of this pipeline if this is
a transformer transform the data set if
this is the estimator train a model and
use the model to transform the data set
to the next step so after you feed a
pipeline it becomes a fitted pipeline a
pipeline model and that is also a
transformer and for evaluator is given
the predictions and labels and try to
give you a metric that's a double value
so those are the basic concept of
pipeline and if you have already
familiar ways that you learned so you
should be familiar with those concepts
already but we try to just have our own
design and to fit the Big Data world the
first part is very proposed some
interface for multimodal training and
it's very important is if you can change
a model with multiple data sets because
you have if you have a big data set
surely you don't really care about the
computation it's most of the computation
time is caused by communication it's
just how many passes you need to make to
a data set so you're late you won't you
just embed multiple training processes
into a single pass and just to
so here that the interface is you supply
a list of parameter sets and I give you
a list of models in this way you can for
example compute multiple gradients in a
single pass oh you can you can broadcast
the data set and two different worker
nodes and the trend most separate models
in parallel and then crack back all the
models and that's the way you can
paralyze single machine showers and the
other part we will change the succulent
designs how we specify parameters and in
second let you specify parameters by
strings and this is how you specify
parameters in sec you learn the hashing
underscore TF is the ID for the pipeline
component and then underscore underscore
that separates the parameter name from
the from the component ID and then you
set number features you choose from one
thousand to ten thousand and this is not
that user-friendly because it's very
easy to make mistakes ratio and
sometimes you don't it's hard to
discover those mistakes and yeah my lip
is we try to say the parameter is a
member of the the component and you can
just tap in the parameters and with
references parameters outside the
component scope and you see you can say
hashing TF thought number features but
this is nice because if you are work on
their integrated development environment
or you are working on their console with
code completion
it can come autocomplete for you and I
can also ensure some help messages into
this dis up prom instance so you can get
self-contained docks and the next step
is how to tune a estimator how to tune
models and we implemented cross
validation and which is agnostic to the
underlying estimator and the evaluator
remember how we defined estimator and
how we define evaluator so the cross
validator doesn't need to know about
what the asking
is it could be a logistic regression
because it's a estimator it could be a
pipeline because the pipeline itself is
a estimator so in this way we can
actually tune the entire pipeline easily
and here we say let's tune this pipeline
using this evaluator and raise those
this parent grid and just always number
four 3s right so that's easy and so
there are couple work in progress it's
definitely not complete so the first
power is attributes about to provide
future attributes like names like if
this is a categorical data what other
categories I want to add more future
transformers like how to turn a
categorical feature into binary features
and also we want to just remove all more
algorithms and there is a pipeline API
so there are more choices you can use
and then well we need to figure out how
to persist a pipeline so after you train
up a plan definitely you don't want to
respond maybe ten hours to return the
entire pipeline let's you should be able
to save them to disk and also because in
1.4 we are going to have spark or in
spark we also want to provide the same
pipeline API in spark our that's the
working progress for pipelines okay so
that now let's go to the second part of
my talk
it's a we talked about higher level API
snow we really want to go to the lower
level powered how we optimize the
algorithm such that they are scalable I
want to use this example because I hope
being spent well reservable time on just
optimizing alternate least squares it is
for collaborative filtering so if you
already know collaborative filtering and
it's you have a rating matrix you have
some user item and the ratings if you
already know it this is also a Sudoku
you can spend some time on it so
basically you have some observer
readings and I point out a question mark
here in the middle and what what should
this user
ray this atom Oh give me the predictive
rating if this is a spool so basically
you you know it's if you spend couple
hours on it that's a nine and so but if
I say all the ratings are independent
then you don't have a good way to to say
about what the values should be right we
need some rules like Sudoku and we need
some assumptions here to how to
reconstruct this matrix and the
assumption here is the low-rank
assumption and basically think about if
I asked question what kind of movie do
you lack so you don't just return a list
of movies and let me figure out right so
it suggests that you tell maybe sci-fi
or maybe cry an action that I know your
tastes and purely this this preference
is taking place in a lower dimensional
latent space and we can't just use inner
product we can map all the maybe users
movies to this latent space and use
inner product error to estimate the
ratings and with that model actually so
we have this low rack assumption the
rating matrix a here is approximately
the multiplication between U and V and
each of them is a rank okay is a tall
and skinny matrix and so this is how we
evaluate the model how to find the U and
the V oh definitely well for example if
I say I love colored movies
well it doesn't tell you much about my
tastes right so we need to find the
right descriptor for my preference and
but the algorithm doesn't know much
about it we need to find some objective
for it the easiest one is the
reconstruction error so we can just do
this the Frobenius norm of a minus u
transpose V but the problem here is
there are a lot of observed readings and
we cannot just define this objective we
cannot compute it because there are so
many unknowns and then the solution is
simple is let us just check about what
we have seen and let's just do this
estimate the recon sir
the error on those ratings and so this
is the objective function the bottom
part and then about this object of what
is clear this is the objective but it's
not that clear how to solve it because
it's it's not convex a compact convex
means your Lim is easy to solve and
there's a unique optimal solution this
is not convex but if we fix one side
remember we have the U times V if we fix
you and solve for V actually this
problem becomes really nice it's a
convex problem and is separable
but separable if I write the red object
have done in this form you see it
actually is a sum of small objects and
those those objectives are independent
of each other so we can solve those
subproblems separate in in parallel so
this algorithm is really about good for
parallel computation and for each
subproblem is a least square problem so
that's why this is called alternating
little squares we take alternating
directions and for each direction we
solve a lot of little square problems
and the complexity and to solve a little
square problem of size and by hey you're
living in NK square time and show the
total computation cost is the number of
readings times K square remember if we
want to skill up to maybe couple
buildings and times K square K is your
late entente 30 but that's that's a
really large scale here and for each one
we use this called normal equation
approach you know as to shove it the
storage requirement is kind of K square
just to start a transpose a then if well
just a regular paper well we are done
here
so it's a nice algorithm and we do some
experiments my experiments and it works
well it beats the base one and we can
publish the paper but for for SPARC well
we can ascend here we need to think
about how to implement this algorithm on
spark
so I'm sure we need to how to skill up
for example in 1.1 we have an
implementation it's already a good
implementation that can scale up to
couple buildings but now while their
users ask for more and I spent some time
just to think about how to scale up to
100 buildings ratings and then while we
can I think maybe we can just deal with
really large data sets and the first
part is always communication when you
just translate our part algorithm to a
parallel system it's a think about
communication and if you want to say we
want to handle billions of readings with
millions of users and items we have to
distribute the ratings on two different
machines and then the question is how we
distribute the data and I see maybe the
first choice is owed to all and for each
factor
remember we in the alternating
directions we fix you and the cell for V
we have vectors for factors for all the
atoms and then we use those feature
vectors to solve for user vectors and
now this is a graph to describe the
ratings basically if there is a
connection is there's a observed ratings
and suppose we have you and now let's
solve for V and V 1 is connected with u
u 1 and u 2 that means we need to send
the vector u 1 back to u 2 to V 1 and 4
V 2 we need to send u 1 u 2 & u 3 and if
we do it in this way we shuffle a lot
it's just basically the number of
readings times k k is the length the
size of a vector and but this is maybe a
still other magnitude smaller than the
computation cost if you remember is the
number of readings times K square
however is a computation is happening
inside CPUs is much faster than just a
transferring data
so even the surface has number of
radians times K this is a lot remember
you may have already helped our
by some ratings now it's time you need
to tell me whiskey and that's maybe well
you cannot even store the cellphone
files and also the other part is sending
too much
it's a for example if we want and we
chew on the same machine and we
shouldn't send you one twice which was
just sent you one once to that machine
so we can do this
plug to palak common communication for
example let's put u1 and u2 on our
machine called p1 and the u3 machine
happy to and now same
similarly we group reven v2 into q1 and
v3 and v4 into q2
now we know I only need to send you one
to Q 1 and u 2 to Q 1 u 3 to Q 1 and but
we for each target block that's Q and we
only need to send a vector once not
multiple times and inside the q1 I know
but let's extract the sub graph from the
previous graph I know how to compute V
van from u u1 v1 v1 from u 1 u 2 and V 2
from u 1 u 2 u 3 so basically in this
way we can save a lot of communication
by just sending a vector to a block
rather than to an individual atom and
then we call P 1 P 2 will come out
blocks because those blocks our
information is for this user vector
which target item block as you sent to
write this is called art blog and the
for q1 recorded in blocks basically for
each item and which user factor as you
use and it's the subgraph described in
the in the Q block and this is our data
structure used in the an ellipse
implementation and if you check clear
closely we see will actually be we can
in this way we can actually cache p1 p2
those in blogs and the out blocks then
in each iteration we only shuffle the
of actors we really need to sell for
shall we extra data but if you look at
it carefully we actually catch two
copies of ratings it's a full user in
blocks and be kind of like a copy of the
original ratings and for item in blocks
they are different we can catch another
copy and this is the very common in this
distributed implementation of machine
learning algorithms we just try to save
communication just by have duplicating
the data and the next part is since we
want to put two copies of the ratings
maybe we should find the efficient
storage for it and we want to save
storage and let's talk about the storage
format for in blocks and well remember
in blocks is kind of the subgraph for
for add for items and we can just all a
list of reading top holes and for q1
this is for q1 just go back here that
says Oh
small sub graph on the top right corner
and we have those five readings however
if we install it in this way and also in
Java and there's a huge storage overhead
remember it's a health example have a
first typo it's called V by u 1 a 1 1
and that's an integer integer and a
float and but we use a top hole to store
it the top hole takes a extra pointer
that's a long so if you add them up the
overhead is kind of like curve well a
lot maybe 50 percent and also it created
a lot of object inside your virtual
machine you have billions of tuples and
it give you a really high pressure to
the garbage collection I really see a GC
pulse is the means that the VM is
opposing it doesn't do anything just for
GC surely this is bad for well
distributed computation so we need to
optimize the storage format and we
switch to a primitive erase and now
let's just
anthems in array and users in array
under the corresponding ratings in this
way we only have three objects that's a
three permitted primitive arrays so it's
very low to see pressure and then we
need to fold each each item we need to
construct remember we need to construct
this least square problem to solve it
and but the items are we we want B to V
1 V 2 V 2 so we need to construct all
subproblems together because they are
not in a certain order we need to first
receive V 1 we construct the least
square problem so V 1 and then we see V
2 we start constructing a least square
problem for V 2 that means we need to
hold we need to hold all those leases
for our problems
partially subscribe problems in memory
that we need n times K square storage on
this partition and euerle n is already a
couple million but now you want to tell
me with a K square it's very easy to run
out of memory
and then yeah let's let make the the
items ordered by V 1 V 1 V 2 V 2 V 2 and
now well of course the users and the
readings are ordered accordingly and now
we can just construct subproblems and to
solve those problems one by one and that
means we saved the memory requirement
from n K Square to K square we only need
a single instance and we just keep
constructing it solve it clear the
content and construct another subproblem
and we also need to find a way how to
how to solve a race and this is a very
classical problem but we need to start a
race for 3 in parallel if there's a
three arrays to be uttered and we use it
as team shot it's the default method in
Java 7 but not in Java 6 and basically
equal less number of objects than quick
shot and is very useful for sorting
really big data and this is the default
in spark I'll show the sort method we
use to to win the benchmark
and after that we see if you go back is
in V 1 V 1 V 2 V 2 V 2 but they're
duplicate at user items let's just
compress items we only say we want v2
and then keep the keeper index to track
which ranch is for v1 which range is for
me too
and then we don't have duplicate items
but then the problem is you still have
to look for vectors for user vectors for
example I want to see v1 is with v u 1
and I want to construct this a little
square problem I want to get a u1 actor
from the out blocks but I need to
construct a map to get a UN vector but
map lookups is expensive also it's not
memory efficient remember we are at
really large scale and we don't want to
construct a hash map of well millions of
items that's not that efficient so we we
just end up with only store the block
IDs and the local indices instead of the
original user IDs and because I don't
really need to know there are no user
IDs and I can't remember the graph for
q1 I got vectors from p1 I got vectors
from a p2 I won't need to remember maybe
I only use the first vector from P 1 and
the second vector from P 2 and that's
all I need to know to construct the
construct the least square problem so I
only need to start the block IDs and
local indices rather than the user IDs
and now we can also just encode those
two integers into a single integer using
the higher pitch to stop block IDs and
use a lower base to stir our local
indexes because surely the partition is
done in a random fashion and such that
the number of readings on each partition
is relatively balanced so if the total
number of users is less than 4 billion
duralee that's the case so we can't just
split an integer into two parts and a
stop block ID and in the first part as
local index in the second part so this
is the experiments experimental result
we have the first test the Amazon
reviews dataset they make copies of a to
just not to scale it up and you see the
graph here the blue line is my hood and
because in each iteration need to just
resolve all the data is very slow it
cannot relays go up to to a reasonable
scale and for Emily in 1.2 is much
better than a hood but you see in 1.3
after we implement all these
organizations is kind of like at least
two acts faster and um where life skill
is kind of like a 4 X - 5 X faster and
it's very stable you don't see a lot of
a GC happening and then we went to a
really big dataset it's a 15 node using
a 15 node R 3 ax large cluster while
barcode transfer and we run on a 30
billion ratings and above 15 million
users and the 20 million items this is a
really large data set we can finish the
tiny variations in just one over and
with rank 10 and actually this is a very
good result we also tested events go
through even larger 100 billion readings
but I forgot the the timing here so
let's recap here how we optimize how a
skill algorithm first we save
communication by just duplicating data
and this is have seen in many
distributed algorithms we try to use
efficient storage to reduce the GC
overhead and to save memory requirement
and we also use some native I didn't
mention here use native plus and APEC
routines to accelerate the linear
algebra operations and that's the way we
skill errors to billions of readings so
yeah that's my talk and we really want
to make an OLAP easy and a scalable
machine learning library and for users
in the
straight show for the pipeline API and
is still experimental and I want to see
whether we can stabilize it in the next
release so please do check it out and
check spark a little document and trace
a pipeline example and try to map your
existing pipelines into this pipeline
API and see how it fits and just let me
know if it doesn't work well for your
application and we can still have time
to change and the second part is well we
tried very hard to just to have a good
scalability and we try to design an
algorithm correctly and we tried to use
the acceleration 9/3 we're also testing
some GPU libraries to accelerate linear
algebra libraries linear algebra
operations and those are a few links
here spark our website remember we are
hiring and also we had spark summit
yesterday sparks at least if you missed
it there will be videos on one watch the
YouTube spark channel and we also have a
spark Sam advised in San Francisco this
June ok thank you
questions
it
yeah yeah
right
so the question is how to transport data
transfer data through different language
api's SPARC is implemented in Scala and
folks for the data frames API is
actually all the data stays in the in
the on the scholar side and the Java the
Python side we only host a pointer to
the Scala side and when you really need
the data on the Python side we use as
Python 4G and that's a library connected
to Python with JVM machine and through
sockets and we try to serialize the data
from the SPM on the JVM set to the Java
side to the Python side and but if you
do this dinner frames operations
actually nothing happens is happening on
the Python side so you get native
performance as well the only part is a
has a overhead is you want the data alt
you want to see the data in Python is
through sockets
yep
right so if you have UDF's defined in
Python and you want to use it in the new
pipeline and definitely we need to go
through this data serialization part
otherwise we cannot understand your UDF
in python well you said that Scala code
we have to talk to the Python set there
will be there is an overhead but we try
to provide common UDF's
so you don't have to define your own
impression in most cases
No so the question is one way is just a
translate data from P to Q and those
from user art blocks to anthem in blocks
we want to have a lot of partitions and
we have fixed number of partitions but
during the shuffle and the for example
for p1 and you need to store it has a
sample file indicate which pointers
indicate this part is going to q1 and
this part is going to kill - that's the
well that's a common falafels
about the number of partitions stay the
same
non linear SVM we don't have right now
for SVM we only have an implementation
for linear SVM and where's our how-to
and our one recreation
in TCP
it's the overall communication you sum
up all the communication cost but I
think it's through TCP that's true when
you actually use not sure I think we use
our car fold for this message
broadcasting or message sending messages
and the underlying is I actually am not
sure
so which particle uses
yeah
yep
there's not much overhead but you
definitely you don't want to do level 1
or level two blasts operations and in
native code because there will be some
overhead but for level 3 because the
commutation cost is kind of like an
Ncube so even you just eat that overhead
is still faster than your Java
implementation and we called it hit
blast and our impact hole through a
library called net-lib Java and it
provides a Java interface for some black
blast like interface and underlined it
has a GI layer and then talk to the
native code
oh sorry
oh say the question is option of spark
show mateus creator of spark I gave a
talk yesterday a spark summit and right
now we have I think more than 500
companies are using spark in production
and there is also a wiki page called
powered by spark and there is a list of
companies and one sentence describing
their use cases you can check it out so
the spark is a open source project is
the Apache project h2o is a is a machine
learning project from hacks data and I
think we H to provide some integration
with spark through this serialize
through RDD to their data frames and you
can you can run machine learning
algorithms on top of it but the just two
different libraries
yeah
here is a foam safe and a load in 1.3 we
added the save and load function to
general linear models and naivebayes
alternating little squares and all the
tree resembles decision tree and random
forest and you can say after you chill
model you can just call save and we'll
use parquet to save the model but it's
not available in the pipeline API so the
next step will be well let's do that in
the pipeline API you can save the entire
pipeline and that will be really good
and after you can produce your model and
you can always load it back and run
predictions will spark streaming okay
thank you